- [Narrator] Gosan Abdu
Idris is a man with a mission
to end child marriage, and he's
doing it with the one thing
he has at his disposal:
His voice.
(speaking foreign language)
(uplifting music)
Gosan has experienced,
firsthand, the institution,
which he hopes, himself, to end.
Child marriage puts women at
a particular disadvantage,
because they are often
removed from school.
With four children,
three of them daughters,
Gosan works to educate men
and women in his community
against this practice.
Gosan hosts talks.
(speaking foreign language)
He speaks with men about
the the disadvantages
of keeping girls out of school.
He talks about allowing kids, to be kids.
And it works!
Many people have changed their minds.
Being exposed to these new
ideas has had a positive effect.
For Gosan, it all comes back to family
and to his daughters.